a pesar de que data de 45 años atrás los
franceses siguen confundiendo se los
cambiamos de hora esta noche vamos hacia
atrás
vamos hacia adelante
cada vez nos olvidamos si tenemos que
prevenirnos no olvides cambiar la hora a
las 3 de la madrugada del domingo los
relojes retrocedieron a las 2 de la
mañana lo que significa otros 60 minutos
de sueños necesarios hasta el último
domingo de marzo el sol saldrá y se
pondrá antes pero cada uno tiene su
opinión al respecto
me gusta el cambio de hora porque aporta
un poco de locura a nuestra vida
cotidiana
es inútil cambiar la hora es inútil
muchos franceses están deseando que se
elimine el cambio por completo del total
móvil es totalmente ridículo llevamos
más de 40 años hablando de ello y
seguimos sin cambiarlo debería
permanecer la misma hora todo el año
perturba a los agricultores al
comportamiento de las vacas así que no
es una buena idea
el sistema horario de verano se
introdujo por primera vez en 1917 para
sincronizar las horas de actividad
económica y la luz del día ya que al
haber más sol se utiliza menos
electricidad el sistema fue abolido
después de la primera guerra mundial y
se restableció en 1976 en plena crisis
del petróleo pero en los últimos años
han aumentado el número de bombillas de
bajo consumo y el efecto del cambio de
horas se ha vuelto menos significativo
hace tres años estos argumentos llevaron
al parlamento europeo a votar el fin del
cambio de hora pero hasta el momento los
estados miembros no han conseguido
alcanzar un consenso unificado